-Hey, YouTube, here with
her solo debut performance
of her new single, "Lalisa,"
it's Lisa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Singing in foreign language ]
♪♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ La, la-la-la, la, la-la-la ♪
♪ La, la-la-la ♪
♪ What's my name?
What's my name? ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ La, la-la-la, la, la-la-la ♪
♪ La, la-la-la ♪
♪ What's my name?
What's my name? ♪
[ Singing in foreign language ]
♪♪
♪ Burn, burn, burn ♪
[ Singing in foreign language ]
♪ Champagne ♪
♪ Sip, sip ♪
[ Singing in foreign language ]
♪ Want you to ring the alarm ♪
♪ Say, "Lalisa, love me,
Lalisa, love me" ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ Call me, "Lalisa, love me" ♪
♪ "Lalisa, love me" ♪
♪ Hey ♪
[ Singing in foreign language ]
♪ The loudest in the room,
hoo, hoo ♪
♪ Just say, "Lalisa, love me,
Lalisa, love me" ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ Call me, "Lalisa, love me" ♪
♪ "Lalisa, love me" ♪
♪ Hey ♪
[ Singing in foreign language ]
♪ The loudest in the room, hoo ♪
♪ Baby, get the megaphone ♪
♪ Put it on speaker ♪
♪ I said I can't hear you ♪
♪ So you need to speak up ♪
♪ Put that...on stereo ♪
♪ Everyone else on very low ♪
♪ Protect it like a barrier ♪
♪ Promise there's nothing
scarier ♪
♪ Than me if anybody
coming gunnin' for my man ♪
♪ Gonna catch a case,
gun up in my hand ♪
♪ Bam, bam, bam,
hit after hit though ♪
♪ Rocks in my wrist,
so I call 'em the Flintstones ♪
♪ Ring the alarm ♪
[ Singing in foreign language ]
♪ Say, "Lalisa, love me,
Lalisa, love me" ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ Call me, "Lalisa, love me" ♪
♪ "Lalisa, love me" ♪
♪ Hey ♪
[ Singing in foreign language ]
♪ The loudest in the room,
hoo, hoo ♪
♪ Just say, "Lalisa, love me,
Lalisa, love me" ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ Call me, "Lalisa, love me" ♪
♪ "Lalisa, love me" ♪
♪ Hey ♪
[ Singing in foreign language ]
♪ The loudest in the room, hoo ♪
♪ You gon' still love me ♪
♪ You need some L-A-L-I-S-A ♪
[ Singing in foreign language ]
♪ Love you some L-A-L-I-S-A ♪
♪ Hoo ♪
♪ You cannot see me ♪
[ Singing in foreign language ]
♪ Went for the throat ♪
♪ Being the greatest of all time
ain't fantasy ♪
[ Singing in foreign language ]
♪ Belongs to we, Blackpink ♪
♪ Lalisa, Lalisa, Lalisa ♪
[ Singing in foreign language ]
♪ Catch me if you can ♪
♪ Lalisa, Lalisa,
Lalisa, Lalisa, Lalisa ♪
♪ Say, "Lalisa, love me,
Lalisa, love me" ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ Call me, "Lalisa, love me" ♪
♪ "Lalisa, love me" ♪
♪ Hey ♪
[ Singing in foreign language ]
♪ The loudest in the room,
hoo, hoo ♪
♪ Just say, "Lalisa, love me,
Lalisa, love me" ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ Call me, "Lalisa, love me" ♪
♪ "Lalisa, love me" ♪
♪ Hey ♪
[ Singing in foreign language ]
♪ The loudest in the room, hoo ♪